es gibt die geschichte dass der
oberbürgermeister der stadt duisburg der
große organisator und herr anwohner der
loveparade gewesen ist absoluter unsinn
herr sauerland wir sind hier an einem
besonderen ort dieser raum ist in gut
bekannt sie waren am tag ihre abwahl
hier was ist denn da passiert
wir haben uns hier getroffen haben
in diesem raum mit freundin gewartet wie
die ergebnisse sind
ich war damals ziemlich sicher das
reicht der abfall initiative denn ein
jahr jeden tag zu leben zu lesen und mit
zu kriegen dass dort jemand
oberbürgermeister ist der 21 menschen
auf dem gewissen hat
das war der vorwurf der 560 leute zu
verantworten hat die traumatisiert durch
die welt gehen
da war ich mir ziemlich sicher das gibt
mehr als 25 prozent zustimmung zur
abwahl aber auch damals den weg
ich bin den weg eingegangen weil ich
gesagt habe wir als stadt sind nicht
ursache dieses wirklich dramatischen
ereignisses wir tragen nicht die
verantwortung die art und weise wie man
darüber berichtet ist völlig an der
realität vorbei immer vielleicht mehr
jetzt in die gegenwart
jetzt steht der zehnte jahrestag ist das
für sie also wie sind diese jahrestage
für sie
insgesamt haben sie da vorher schon
irgendwie komische gefühle und wie ist
dieser jahreszeit zehnte jahres hat ist
es etwas besonderes es ist etwas
besonderes
ich werde mich auch mit vielen die da zu
schaden gekommen sind treffen oder sagen
was eingeschränkt mit einigen weil viele
werden nicht kommen so ist hat mir
berichtet
und diejenigen zu denen ich zugang habe
den werde ich helfe
an diesem tag so weit ist die
möglichkeit habe jeden duisburg zu
verbringen so wie ich das auch bei den
letzten jahrestagen gemacht habe ohne
dass ich das laut verkündet
ziehen sie sich in irgendeiner weise ist
teil dieser kuppel weil sie ja auch
nützlich als 3
also es ist schwierig zu fahrten zu
beantworten ich bin teile der gruppe
aber ich bin ein anderer teil als
diejenigen die vor mir sitzen die die
vor mir sitzen sind menschen die haben
im wahrsten sinne des wortes den tod in
die augen geschaut
ich war nicht da ich war von der rampe
500 meter entfernt die konnte die rampe
nicht sehen ich weiß nicht was da
passiert ist
ich habe hinweise gekriegt das dann was
passiert war als ich von der
pressekonferenz gab aber ich musste mir
das nicht mit ansehen
ich habe die tod nicht gesehen ich habe
die schlimme situation danach natürlich
berichtet gekriegt aber das was
diejenigen mit denen ich da so zusammen
wenn alles erlebt haben haasis absolut
heller wagen sind deutschland an dem an
dem tag selbst würde ich sagen wir gehen
vielleicht jetzt einmal um das ganze
auch einzuordnen müssen wir schon an den
tag selbst gehen erzählt sie uns einfach
mal wie sie diesen tag erlebt haben sie
waren ja anfangs gar nicht da haben sie
mir gesagt sondern kann vielleicht
erzählen sie das mal
also es gibt die geschichte dass der
oberbürgermeister der stadt duisburg der
große organisator und heran hohler der
loveparade gewesen ist ist absoluter
unsinn
der rvr
hat als die berliner sagten die wollen
die loveparade nicht mehr in berlin
haben dort der zuständige mann für
öffentlichkeitsarbeit hat sich gleich
gemeldet und hat gerufen das kontern im
ruhrgebiet basiert der verband er
verheißt der kvr dieser frau
kommunalverband ruhe ist ein verband in
essen
wer so mehr oder weniger koordiniert die
sachen im ruhrgebiet die haben auch eine
werbeabteilung und da hat der zuständige
mann dann gerufen
das könnte das ruhrgebiet übernehmen
solche veranstaltungen nur um das
einzuordnen die anderen nicht wollten im
ruhrgebiet ins ruhrgebiet zu holen es
einen verhaltensmuster im ruhrgebiet
was ich für völlig daneben halte
und deshalb war ich schon von anfang an
derjenige der gesagt hat also wir machen
gerne hier veranstaltungen wir machen
auch schöne veranstaltungen aber wir
übernehmen nicht veranstaltungen die
irgendwo anders nicht mehr gewollt sind
ich hab dann diese ganze entscheidung in
den rat gegeben
der rat der stadt duisburg musste
entscheiden ob die stadt duisburg dann
akzeptiert dass 2010 die loveparade in
duisburg stattfindet die abstimmung war
bei gegenstimmen einer fraktion die
gesagt hatte kostet uns zu viel geld
einstimmig es gab da noch mal eine
sondersitzung zu diesem thema kurz vor
der loveparade hat eine fraktion eine
sondersitzung des rates einberufen und
wollte schließen und hat beschließen
lassen dass die stadt kein geld dazu
gibt die vorlage war einstimmig dass
keiner mehr gestimmt also eine ganze rat
hat zwei kurz vor der loveparade
beschlossen wir wollen in duisburg die
loveparade
am tag selbst waren also ich wollte
jetzt nur mein verein ist so loveparade
darstellen
eigentlich wollte ich zur laufprojekt
gar nicht in duisburg sein meine familie
hatte geplant wir fahren eine woche in
urlaub
wir waren die in österreich und genau an
neben wochenende wo die loveparade
stattfand
wir haben in österreich gibt es eine
schutzhütte die heißt schutz stadt
duisburg oder duisburg und die hat die
jubiläums und dann fragte man mich ob
ich dazu kommen würde
zu diesem jubiläum gesagt ja ich bin in
österreich der fall ich da meinen also
sehr schöner wusste gar nicht dass es so
was gibt ja aber dann haben diejenigen
die sagte das geht nicht du musst kommen
du musst mindestens da sein wenn die
zahlen verkündet werden damit ich also
samstags samstags war die loveparade
freitags nachts von österreich nach
duisburg gefahren und bin gegen
nachmittag oder frühen frühen nachmittag
soll der übergangszeit mittag nach meter
dann mit meinem ohr weil der verkehr in
der innenstadt mit sperrung der a59 war
ja natürlich wahnsinn habe ich mich dann
aus dem duisburger norden durchgekämpft
zum pressezentrum
da habe ich dann das erste mal das
gelände gesehen und habe festgestellt so
ganz viele wollen nicht nicht waren
viele aber nicht die zahlen wie
prognostiziert wurden
sie müssen wissen wie wir jetzt sind war
bei einem ganz leidigen thema wenn sie
gehört haben was gesagt wurde während
des prozesses zu diesen zahlen
da hat jemand der federführend dieser
veranstaltung ist gesagt dass die zahlen
die man immer in die öffentlichkeit
gebracht hat während alles nur medien
zahlen gewesen sprachen von 1,5
millionen bei der loveparade in duisburg
waren auf dem platz nie mehr als 200.000
wenn sie das überhaupt waren
was wäre gewesen wenn da gibt es
wirklich ein mann hat millionen menschen
auf kreuzer es ging gar nicht wie sie es
gibt parameter die schon von vornherein
gezeigt haben dass es gar nicht so viel
werden können
90 prozent derjenigen die zur loveparade
kamen und gekommen sind kamen mit dem
zug die kapazität die züge überhaupt
hatten an dem tag nach duisburg waren
gar nicht so hoch dass es 200.000
überschritten werden konnten
ja sie hinkamen war es also noch nicht
ganz voll waren also noch nicht es war
es war das maximum
aber wenn sie sich die bilder anschaue
die auch gemacht wurden um vom hochhaus
das sehen sie da war platz ohne ende und
dann sie irgendwann davon erfahren ist
was richtig schief mann war in dem
moment sieht es das war nach der
pressekonferenz aber ich musste dann zur
pressekonferenz und auf dem weg zur
pressekonferenz signalisierte man mir
dass irgendwas im tunnel im gang und ja
und keine kommunikation und neben tunnel
ist kein empfangen und sie wissen es gab
keine vorrangschaltung für die
sicherheitskräfte
die leute die dort entscheidungen
treffen mussten wussten gar nicht was da
unten passiert weitet und das wissen wir
jetzt auch seit den aussagen im prozess
die bilder die man gemacht hat vom
hubschrauber gar nicht zur analyse
benutzt wurden
auf den bildern hätte man das sehen
können dass es datenstau gehabt auf
jeden fall da gab es hinweise
da habe ich meine meine prognose der
zahlen genannt 1,5 millionen aber habe
ich gesagt waren bei der loveparade
befanden sich in der stadt duisburg
anlässlich der loveparade wenn wir jetzt
mal 250.000 bis 500.000 duisburger
nehmen wahr dass multiplikator von zwei
und nicht und multiplikator von 78 die
die veranstalter früher genannt weil wir
waren diese zahlen einfach weil jenseits
der realität nicht zahlen die ich
unbedingt verkünden musste
dann haben sie auch die pressekonferenz
genannt obwohl sie wussten dass nicht
korrekt sind
sie kennen ja die zahlen ich kenne die
zahlen von dortmund sie kennen die
zahlen von essen
sie sind so gelaufen und alle haben
geschrieben 1,5 millionen liefen durch
essen 1,5 millionen oder 1,4 millionen
liefen durch dortmund es war nicht so es
waren vielleicht so viele menschen da
wenn man die bevölkerung damit zu
rechnen
aber
anlässlich der veranstaltung leider
nicht und diese veranstaltung war eine
veranstaltung die keiner braucht aber
die man unbedingt wollte und nach dieser
ansprache von ihnen wie wie hat sich die
situation dann entwickelt ich bin dann
darunter gekommen dann sagte man mir
jetzt gibt dann auf dem weg zum größten
hochhaus es gibt da einen toten
ja und ich hab dann kollegin von hinten
getroffen
eine kollegin vom wdr habe ich dann in
den tunnel geschickt habe gesagt
jedenfalls ist da los war es aber noch
nichts genaues bin dann informiert
worden dass das dauert menschen ums
leben gekommen sind die erste prognose
war
die habe ich von dem leiter unserer
feuerwehr gekriegt weil die alle in
einer reihe lagen dass sie wohl oben vom
gitter vom geländer unter gefallen sind
war natürlich nicht aber das war die
prognose aus sicht der dessen der dauert
im einsatz war und das war das einzige
was er sich erklären konnte ist doch
keiner davon ausgegangen dass man sich
da gegenseitig tod getrieben hat welche
positionen und rollern sie dann in dem
moment gehörte gange
ich musste ich muss oder ich sollte da
sein um die zahlen zu verkünden
und das war auch alles aber sie haben ja
wahrscheinlich einen ziemlichen schreck
bekommen ist dieses geschenk das es aber
leicht untertrieben
ich hab dann also zu anfang sei das
fragten sie ob das wirklich realität ist
keiner hat damit gerechnet
wenn man bedenkt was da dafür
vorbereitungen getroffen wurden dass
dieses nicht passiert und dann passiert
so was
es war für alle nicht zu glauben würde
dass dann nicht sofort alles abgebrochen
sie nicht gekommen weil wenn sie
abgebrochen hätten
und 200.000 leute hätten dann versucht
nach hause zu kommen das wäre hat so hat
die einsatzleitungen dann entschieden
das wäre dann zu einem richtigen chaos
gekommen
man hat das weiterlaufen lassen damit
sich dann die menschen von dem von dem
platz in ruhe weg bewegen konnten und
kein zweites kein zweiter entsteht
sie kannten ja die ganzen räumlichen
gegebenheiten als duisburger kann ihnen
da jemals vorher der gedanke so ein
tunnel und so viele leute und alles nur
in eine richtung
wenn ich will ihnen versuchen das zu
erklären anhand eines anderen beispiel
stellen sie sich vor sie bauen ein haus
sie gehen hin wenn sie genug geld haben
und schauen nach einem grundstück und
gucken ob das grundstück gefällt und
ihren anforderungen entspricht
danach überlegen sie sich wie ihr haus
aussieht und dann wenn sie mit sich im
reinen sind und vorstellungen haben
was machen sie dann dann gehen sie zu
leuten die davon ahnung haben die nennen
sich architekten die nennen sich
statiker und dann geben sie die aufträge
und lassen dann überprüfen das ist nicht
die aufgabe gewesen der stadt duisburg
das wusste jeder die loveparade ist eine
privatveranstaltung und für diese ganzen
sachen war der veranstalter zuständig
und auch verantwortlich er sucht
mithilfe oder ohne hilfe der stadt ein
grundstück auf dieses grundstück waren
privatgrundstück der privatmann des
grundstückes hat der loveparade dieses
grundstück zur verfügung gestellt er
musste prüfen
reichen die zuwegungen reichen die
abwägungen wie müssen sie aussehen alles
das hat er machen müssen und vorlegen
müssen
die stadt duisburg ist und das war mehr
als sie machen musste dann hingegangen
und hat all diese planungsunterlagen
einem wirklichen experten zur verfügung
gestellt und hat gesagt schau darüber
kann das funktionieren
er hat das getan dieses gutachten hat
glaube ich 20.000 euro kostet und das
gesagt das funktioniert ist denn sie
lief es für sie weiter sind sie dann
anschließend sofort aus dem gelände nach
der pressekonferenz war das so geplant
dass ich mitglied zum medienzentrum und
dann nach hause fahren sie können sich
vorstellen dass ich nicht mehr nach
hause gefahren bin
ich bin als ich dann daraus konnte im
einsatzzentrum zur feuerwehr gefangen
und war davis nacht bis die letzten auch
von den geräten der weg war
danach sind sie dann nach hause
danach bieten aber wir fahren da würden
die mainzer sind dann fährt man dann
nach hause zu seiner frau nach hause
oder gar nicht im bett nicht mehr fragen
das weiß ich nicht
es gibt dinge die verdrängt man gedacht
das weiß ich nicht mehr
das weiß ich mir jetzt gibt die einfach
sie das war eine situation wo sie auch
sich selbst
existenzielle fragen stellen wir wussten
warum das passiert ist man konnte sehen
aber man hat nicht zu kennen ist
genommen doch zu anfang jahr und erst in
der nacht wechselte dann auf einmal die
stimmung mehr hat jemand danach aus dem
pressebereich gesagt also morgens und
zwar unabhängig von der pressekonferenz
stand für alle klar
und das ist auch nachts dafür gesorgt
worden die stadt duisburg trägt die
schuld und es wurde nichts mehr
diskutiert es war so man fragte nicht
wer wer war dafür verantwortlich wer war
dafür werden weil ich wär musste das
machen also so sachen wie hindernisse
die man nicht weg geräumt hat in der
zuwegung wo neun meter dann auf einmal
nur noch sieben meter waren die wurden
nicht mehr diskutiert die frage gab es
vorher staus wie hat man die aufgelöst
wurden nicht mehr diskutiert hätte man
dieses alles verhindern können das ist
das erste mal darüber gesprochen worden
und da gibt es ja dann auch äußerungen
zur vor gericht und das gericht war der
ansicht das hätte alles verhindert
werden können aber nicht von der stadt
duisburg
das ist aber alles nicht mein thema mein
thema ist es haben wir fehler gemacht
habe ich fehler gemacht eben verhalten
danach also ich kann ihnen sagen wenn
sie morgens dann
beschrieben werden als mörder wenn man
ihn nach stellt wenn sie mit der familie
die stadt verlassen um die familie in
sicherheit zu bringen
dann auch noch adäquat reagieren zu
wollen zu können hat sich das so schnell
zugespitzt
ja ich bin am zweiten tag nach der
loveparade mit blumen am ort gewesen
da hat ein kollege von mir mich
verteidigt dass ich da wieder eine pause
gab es ist so schwer gefallen in diesem
moment für diesen moment dieses
mitgefühl und dass das mit empfinden mit
den opfern und den angehörigen so
auszudrücken dass bei den menschen
tatsächlich auch ankommen
sie haben sie standen in der situation
rechtlich das gesagt wurde die stadt
duisburg ist daran schuld
die trägt die verantwortung und sie ich
durfte alles nur nicht irgendetwas
machen was rechtlich dazu geführt hätte
dass es verwertbar gewesen wäre
als schuldeingeständnis ich bin kein
jurist als ehemaliger lehrer hätte ich
wahrscheinlich die worte einfacher
gefunden als in einer situation nachdem
sie juristisch beraten wurden und
deshalb habe ich die worte so gewählt
dass sie auf jeden fall nicht als
schuldeingeständnis der stadt gewertet
werden können
jetzt war es so dass nach der loveparade
wir müssen wissen die stadt duisburg war
eine stadt im haushaltssicherungskonzept
und durfte nicht so einfach freiwillige
ausgaben aufgeben
das land nordrhein westfalen an uns
herangetreten ist und hat gesagt wir
sorgen jetzt dafür dass die angehörigen
ordentlich versorgt werden und betreut
werden
das war für uns nur große
erleichterungen bei der ansonsten hätten
wir gelder freischaufeln müssen und ich
weiß nicht wie der rat der stadt damals
reagiert hätte
wir haben danach nur zeit nachgefragt ob
wir uns nicht mit den angehörigen
treffen können da es immer gesagt worden
ein
sie wollen mit der stadt duisburg keinen
kontakt haben
wir haben dann den kontakt mit der
mutter des duisburger opfers gesucht ich
war damals zusammen mit dem
stadtdirektor dann bei ihr
wir haben uns dann unterhalten wir haben
auch versucht so weit es möglich geht
ist sie zu unterstützen und haben dann
gewartet dass es ein zeichen gibt
wir haben dann auch immer wieder mal
nachgefragt aber immer wieder wurde
gesagt die wollen mit euch nicht reden
dann waren kamen dann der punkt wo es
uns einfach zu bunt war
wir hatten einen beauftragten der stadt
den einen ehemaligen amtsleiter den
haben wir dann auch an den sitzungen
teilgenommen hat die dort organisiert
worden und haben ihn gebeten angehörige
zu fragen ob wir mit ihnen nicht kontakt
aufnehmen dürfen
zwei haben ja gesagt und mit den beiden
familien habe ich mich dann auch
getroffen
im nachgang aber das waren keine sachen
die in die öffentlichkeit zu gehen
den familien war es nicht danach in die
öffentlichkeit zu suchen und sie können
sich vorstellen bei mir war es ähnlich
sie wurden dann quasi in diesen tagen
der nas beraten
was sie sagen nein es wurde gesagt was
das dass wir das ich juristisch
aufpassen muss dass es dort nichts gibt
was irgendwie juristisch verwertbar ist
diese äußerungen von ihnen meinen wunden
immer eine gratwanderung und das präzise
schnitt gefühl und und und rechtlicher
konsequenz ja sie sind heute würde ich
zugeben damals habe ich nicht getan
sie sind auch ein wenig traumatisiert
sie leben dort auch in einer situation
wo sie psychisch damit zurecht kommen
müssen und das war schwierig und das hat
zeit gedauert und dass wir uns heute so
unterhalten können
das wäre im ersten jahr und im zweiten
jahr nie möglich gewesen nie war der
name sauerland in dem moment an und
endlich mit dieser last ist richtig und
zum synonym geworden der 21 toten der
loveparade ihr gefühl wie geht man dann
das kann man nicht beschreiben
aber wie ging es ihnen persönlich haben
sie denn keinen fluchtreflex das gefühl
sie möchten am liebsten so schnell wie
möglich aus wandern ja ich habe einen
fluchtreflex insofern gehabt dass ich
meine familie erst mal zur land
geschickt habe weylandt wurde einfach zu
gefährlich
wir haben dann immer berichte von
unseren nachbarn bekommen was bei uns zu
hause so passierte ich weiß nicht wer da
im kellerloch saß und versucht ihn zu
gucken
wir hatten dort drohungen nicht eine um
jeden tag immer wieder fröhlich neue und
ein kollege von mir auch wenn man damit
als verantwortlichen ausgeguckt hat wir
hatten dann auch hinweise aus der jetzt
neuen lopa 2010 szene dass der eine oder
andere unterwegs sieht messer und
richtung rathaus gaben wir haben einen
sicherheits unternehmen beauftragt das
rathaus zu bewachen
wir hatten morgens am rathaus rote
angepinselt für eingänge mit
entsprechenden sprüchen also wenn man
heute über brutalität im in der
kommunalpolitik und mord an politikern
berichte sieht die hätte man alle 2010
bis 2011 in duisburg live erleben können
also können sie an irgendeiner stelle
nachvollziehen dass die leute so wütend
war ja natürlich
die leute sind mussten so wütend sein
weil sie nie informiert wurden
sie haben die die wahrheit gehört ist
erzählt worden die stadt duisburg trägt
die verantwortung
und diejenigen die wirklich die
verantwortung tragen schauen sich die 42
seiten an
die lebten gut dahin ist das denn
lassen sie das ist nicht mein thema das
ist das thema wer da interesse daran hat
der caganer sich die erklärung des
landgerichts runterladen da steht alles
drin steht alles drin ohne name aber
steht da drin woher sie kommen und was
sie gemacht werden
ich werde keinen keimen beschuldigen das
gut sie sind die verantwortlichen klar
die anzahl
und damit ja auch die kollegen
schuldigen wird es nicht geben
es wird keine schuldigen geben weil
juristisch ist das aufgearbeitet für
mich war wichtig dass darin steht dass
an dieser tragödie die stadt duisburg
keine schuld recht dass es wie war das
dass die unschuldsvermutung auch
weiterhin alle kollegen die dort als
angeklagte waren zu gelten hat es gibt
ja über die juristische verantwortung
hinaus natürlich die frage nach der
moralischen verantwortung wäre es denn
eine option gewesen auch marianne viele
duisburger den ansicht ist hätte
geholfen wenn sie zurückgetreten wären
sie wollten aber nicht zurücktreten
würden sie das im nachgang in konstanz
zurücktreten also wie sieht das aus wenn
man in der krisensituation als chef von
der brücke verschwindet was ist da
einfach nur kneifen und das wollte ich
auf keinen fall meine kollegin meine
kollegen mussten dann alles ertragen
und da kann man nicht erwarten dass dann
der chef sich vom acker macht und sagt
ich habe jetzt ein gutes leben mit
ärztlicher versorgung
hinzu kommt in der verfassung des landes
nordrhein westfalen ist ein rücktritt
des oberbürgermeisters gar nicht
vorgesehen
das hätte natürlich auswirkungen gehabt
bei der entsprechenden versorgung da
will ich ganz ehrlich sein ich hätte
alles an versorgung verloren was ich mir
in den jahren aufgebaut habe weil ich
eigentlich von anfang an als beamter des
landes nordrhein-westfalen und danach
der stadt duisburg keine rentenansprüche
gesicherter wenn sie und da bleib ich
keine verantwortung für dieses drama zu
tragen haben
dann machen sie so gar nichts dann
treten sie nicht zurück es wäre es hätte
es nur möglichkeit gegeben
zurückzutreten jahr in dem der rat der
stadt duisburg beschlossen hätte ich
müsste zurücktreten
das hat er nicht oder indem man abwählt
und den weg muss sich dann gehen
das war kein schöner weg es war auch
kein weg den ich gehen wollte und es war
der einzige weg den ich meiner familie
und mir zumuten konnte
trotzdem müssen diese eineinhalb jahren
eine ziemliche qual für sie gelesen
werden ja das war in vielen sachen
richtig schlimm aber darum geht es nicht
es geht nicht um meine empfindungen aber
sich dadurch zu halten hat jetzt ging
darum dass es am ende nämlich jetzt wo
ich alles juristisch aufgearbeitet ist
soweit es aufzuarbeiten
war eine freiheit gibt darüber zu reden
und auch denjenigen zu sagen wie es
damals nicht verstanden hat dass waren
nicht unsere aufgaben und es waren auch
nicht unsere verantwortungsbereiche es
gibt dort eine verantwortung ja die
verantwortung es gibt auch eine
verantwortung die versagt hat ja sonst
hätte es nicht tote gegeben und soviel
verletzt
aber es war keine kommunale so und ich
bin ja sehr oft gefragt worden
nach moralischer verantwortung und dann
ist ja tut mir leid wenn ich das jetzt
ihnen sagen muss der journalistische
oberbegriff wenn nichts mehr geht dann
definieren wir eine politische
verantwortung ja die gibt's die gibt's
auch in diesem fall einfach nur mal
lesen wo die war nicht in duisburg jetzt
könnte ich würd sagen tu ich nicht weil
ich mich dran
die politische verantwortung ist nie
getragen worden
aber die hätte auch nicht in duisburg
getragen werden müssen sondern da wo die
fehler gemacht wurden sie als
oberbürgermeister nicht hin und wieder
das gefühl wenn sie abends ins bett
gehen dass sie die das wohlbefinden und
und den schutz ihrer bürger ja irgendwie
auch mit auf also auf ihren schultern
tragen also dass diese verantwortung
eben haben und wenn es dann zu so einem
vorfall kommt das ist natürlich ein teil
oder in geringfügiger taiwan wird
irgendwie auch bei ihnen liegt selbst
eine unheimliche geschichten
wenn wir uns die einzelnen punkte
anschauen wie dort wirklich zu diesem
tragischen ereignis geführt haben
dann habe ich immer gesagt wenn der
fehler sind aus dem bereich der
verwaltung trage ich die konsequenz
von anfang an aber ich habe auch
gleichzeitig gesagt diese fehler sind
ich ersichtlich und dann gab es die
erste zeit war die juristische
verantwortung dann merkt man wohl da
kommt man nicht mit weit und dann kommt
immer die politische verantwortung ja
die gibt es und die ist zu tragen indem
politikbereich wo die fehler begangen
wurden und noch mal nicht in duisburg
das ist ja im unterwallis tische
während natürlich schuld in der
bevölkerung sehr weit ausgelegt und
tragen vielleicht auch verbunden dass
man sich nach so einem ereignis in der
kommunikation an die bühne wenn das mag
sein aber ich habe ihnen erklärt warum
das so ist und warum das so war und als
staats gläubiger mensch habe ich auch
damit gerechnet dass diejenigen die die
entsprechenden leute die angehörigen
aber auch die traumatisierten betreut
haben das neutral und im sinne von
traumatisierten und hinterbliebenen
gemacht haben mittlerweile durch den
relativ guten kontakt zu einigen weiß
ich dass es zumindest überprüfen würde
ich meine frau kommt da heute und noch
nicht mit klar meine kinder ja gott
die fanden die zeit im sommer nicht
schön
die fanden die anfeindungen gar nicht
schön aber in ihrem umfeld war das nie
ein thema meine frau stinkesauer auf
diejenigen
die sich so von der bildfläche
verabschiedet haben weil das was sie
durchgemacht hat kann man sich nicht
vorstellen
und ich fand das sehr tapfer dass sie
die zeit durchgehalten hatte es hat
ihnen die energie gegeben weiterzumachen
und sich wieder und die gewissheit dass
wir keine schuld an diesem ereignis
sagen hätte ich gewusst dass da
irgendwas von uns verschuldet wurde
ehrlich gesagt freue der cdu der grünen
tut mir gefallen wählt mich im rat ab
aber das waren diejenigen die zu mir
gehalten haben
und den konnte ich so was dann in dieser
situation nicht abfallen
die haben gesagt wir sind solidarisch zu
dir wir waren immer solidarisch wir
wissen dass wir da keine verantwortung
tragen und wir lassen dich da nicht
hängen
wenn sie sich aussuchen könnten würden
sie das ganze dann noch mal neu
aufrollen und die schuldigen nennen
meint dass ich meine aufgabe es ist die
aufgabe ausschließlich der justiz da die
verantwortung rauszufinden
ausschließlich und gibt keine
institution kann sich definieren wie sie
will
die versucht über nahe juristischen
begrifflichkeiten als vierte institution
drei unter sich zu vereinigen
das gibt es nicht so und da sollten wir
einfach hin zurückkommen
glauben sie mir das hilft das hilft auch
in anderen fällen
wir haben unsägliche diskussion
gottseidank mache ich null politik das
einzige was ich mache
sprecht mit kunden über reisen sie viel
einfacher viel seriöser und ohne
extremismus geführt werden könnten wenn
man sich darauf beruft oder besinnt dass
eine gewaltenteilung gibt 3 und es gibt
an der vierten stelle jemanden der
darüber berichtet und nicht ersatz
institutionen ist aber wenn er berichtet
dann auch wahrheit berichtet wenn sie
rückblickend irgendwo an einer stelle
was anders machen als sie es gemacht
haben
das ist eine frage die kann man
eigentlich nicht beantworten weil sie
müssen einfach verstehen in welcher
situation sie dann sind ja heute mit den
gedanken von heute ja wäre ich da viel
viel freiheit umgegangen
aber damals waren sie nicht frei damals
war man von diesem ereignis gezeichnet
und in so einer situation stellt man
sich nicht
in einer pressekonferenz was heißt das
denn sie werden schnell umgegangen ist
ja ich hätte gesagt passt mal auf
freunde wir haben keine schuld daran
wir kümmern uns jetzt wären nicht auf
das land ein
wir kümmern uns um die menschen die hier
in duisburg zu schaden gekommen sind zu
schaden gekommen sind und ich würde mich
nie mehr darauf einlassen irgendeiner
organisation die betreuung zu übergeben
genau das wir kümmern uns jetzt ruhig
wir kümmern uns jetzt um die menschen
die hier in duisburg das erlebt haben so
und das hätte ich nie gehen lassen an
irgendjemanden wie wäre es denn gewesen
wenn sich mehr menschen der
verantwortung gestellt hätten also wenn
wir dann eine art kollektiv
verantwortung gesprochen hätten hätte
ihnen das geholfen wenn jeder zugegeben
hätte wohl seine fehler gewesen sind
aber wenn jeder zugegeben hätte warum
dieses ereignis so passiert ist wie es
passiert ist hätten wir in duisburg ein
ganz anderes klima gehabt dann hätten
wir gemeinsam helfen können aber das war
ja nicht gewollt es war gewollt dort
einen in die verantwortung zu ziehen
was würden sie sagen kann man aus den
ereignissen lernen dass erstens dass
diejenigen die da waren darüber
schreiben und berichten man nicht meinen
sie müssen sofort werden erstmal nur
berichten und aus den berichten von
allen dann 1 1
ein ergebnis sich entwickeln lassen
in duisburg war es so dass war die die
wertung stand 12 stunden nach dem
ereignis fest und das nicht gut also
sehen sie sich schon als opfer denen sie
nein nein ich also opfer und so solche
begrifflichkeiten würde ich nie
verwenden
ich kann feststellen
man war in der situation nicht bereit
zur wahrheit von der wahrheit und
bereits es gibt eine weit gefächerte
verantwortung her
die gibt es das ist auch denke ich sehr
[Musik]
explizit in der einstellungs begründung
dargestellt worden ja es dieses ereignis
war zum schluss ein ereignis wo viele
viele dinge zusammen kamen die dann dazu
geführt haben dass dieses desaströse
ergebnis entstanden ist
aber für dieses diese verantwortung dort
gibt es auch namen und institutionen es
würden sie jemandem raten der insel
situationen kommt jetzt will sie wenn
ich nicht so gerne oberbürgermeistern
mit herz liebe und zeit gewesen wäre
würde ich ihm raten macht keine politik
aber dass genau dort verkehrte nehmen
würde ich raten gehe in die politik und
sorgt dafür dass die politik sich ins
gute entwickelt und solche ereignisse
nie mehr stattfinden können damit meine
ich nicht es wird immer großkatastrophen
geben
aber das was danach kam nicht mehr
passieren darf dass eine stadt
anderthalb jahre malträtiert wird mit
vorwürfen und mit aussagen die alle
nicht haltbar waren
sie müssen einfach sehen wenn man nicht
weiterkamen hat man die angehörigen der
opfer zitiert ja den wird keiner
widersprechen
keiner da stand da und was man selbst
nicht bereit war zu sagen weil man weiß
da gibt es juristischen nachspiel hat
man dann so dann übermittelt und dass
sie das heute noch tun zeigt die
perversität von einigen leuten ich mich
nochmal einen letzten blick nach vorne
werfen der motten wir jetzt auch wieder
diesen rave in berlin quasi also eine
loveparade unter anderem namen
stattfinden das was denken sie wenn sie
an überhaupt solche großveranstaltungen
in stetten jetzt denken haben sie da
auch schmerzen
die muss man nicht haben und wenn man
sie hat müssen sie am richtigen ort
stattfinden
sie wissen berlin hat parade straßen
da sind sie im osten mit panzer her
gefahren davor im dritten reich mit den
bands an
und danach haben sie jugend
zum ersten mai jugend paraden im osten
durchgeführt dann gibt es straßen die
extra dafür konzipiert sind massen
ereignisse aufzunehmen
also sowas gibt es im ruhrgebiet nicht
wir hatten zwar kaputt aber keine
preußische aufmärsche und sowas
und wenn dr motte das macht in berlin
dann ist dann in berlin
okay aber so was kann man nicht einfach
woanders machen ja auch wenn der msv
noch immer darum kämpft in die zweite
liga zu kommen
wir haben schöne stadien das kann man
nutzen
wir haben schönes umfeld um stadion sie
haben eine ordentlich mittlerweile
ordentlich gastronomie wir haben eine
super regattabahn das sind dinge die wir
hier haben mit dem muss man arbeiten und
nicht mit meiner musik die ich nicht
verstehe und eine veranstaltungsform die
ich auch nicht verstehen die braucht man
nicht
[Musik]